if you go into the water and you see a
great white shark
what's your reaction you're not gonna
think twice
you're hauling ass to get out of there
[Music]
falcons are the great white shark of the
sky and birds are terrified of them
my name is mark adam i am the president
of falcon environmental services
our company uses the world's oldest
sport
falconry to protect planes in flight
[Music]
birds can be really dangerous to
airplanes
if a gulf strikes an engine it can
potentially stop it in which case the
aircraft can come out of the sky
there are multiple methods that airports
can use to control birds sirens another
very common one is pyrotechnics
[Music]
birds
are not dumb they get used to that stuff
but one thing that they can never get
used to
is the instinctive fear of a falcon
here we raise falcons and when they
hatch out we rear them for three or four
days and put them back with the parents
[Music]
the skills that we use to train our
raptors date back to 3000 bc when
falconry was first introduced
utilizing hoods jesses and conditioning
methods
the birds are trained for about 30 to 60
days
where then they go out to our airport
operations
on a given day they are requested
numerous times by the control tower to
intervene at specific spots on the
airfield
at which time the falcon is deployed and
it is allowed to fly around the airport
until the birds have been dispersed
when the falconer wants the falcon to
come back all he has to do is take out
the lure which has a piece of food on it
swing it around his head and the falcon
will come in
in order to be fed
i enjoy bird watching but i find
falconry almost like a chance to see
something that happens every day in the
wild but i get a chance to see it up
close
every day
[Music]
you